imagina que estás en una cafetería de
parís tomando un café con tu mejor amigo
a un francés de la mesa de helado le
cobran 5.30 euros por una taza de café y
un pan dulce después cuando tú pides la
cuenta a ustedes les cobran 14 euros por
dos tazas de café y dos panes de dulce
puedes obtener el precio de cada taza de
café y de cada pan de dulce resolviendo
un sistema de ecuaciones lineales con
dos variables usando esta información si
es que sí cuál es la solución si es que
no cuál es la razón de que no puede
resolverlo así que como siempre lo
primero que vamos a hacer es tratar de
definir variables entonces voy a usar
otra vez x y sea x igual al precio de
una taza de café mientras que voy a
decir que james es igual al precio del
pan dulce que por cierto aquí en esta
foto tenemos un cuernito entonces el
precio del cuerpo
el problema me dice que tenemos que
obtener el precio de la taza de café del
pan de dulce usando un sistema de
ecuaciones así que vamos a ver qué me
dice la primera oración dice que tú
estás con un amigo así claro está que
había un francés en la mesa de al lado y
al francés le cobraron por una taza de
café y por un pan de dulce 5.30 euros
entonces x ma jin es decir una taza de
café más un pan de dulce lo que cuesta
cada uno de ellos medio 5.30 euros esto
es lo que le cobraron al francés ahora
cuánto les cobraron a ustedes tanto a ti
como tu mejor amigo dice bueno ustedes
consumieron dos tazas de café y dos
panes de dulce y entonces les cobraron
catorce euros
esto como lo escribimos en matemáticas
bueno dos tazas de café entonces voy a
multiplicar al precio de matas de café
por dos porque consumimos dos tazas de
café más dos pan de dulce entonces voy a
multiplicar lo que cuesta un pan de
dulce por dos y esto me tiene que dar
igual a 14 euros
2 x 2 es igual a 14 y bueno hay
múltiples formas de resolver este
sistema de ecuaciones puede ser por
igualación suma resta lo que sea pero a
mí se me ocurre que es mucho más fácil
hacerlo por su me restan porque aquí
tenemos el doble de xy el doble de james
así que lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar esta ecuación de aquí por 2
y después de estar una ecuación de la
otra así que si multiplico la primera
ecuación por 2 me va a quedar 2x + 2
james es igual a 5.30 por 2 lo cual es
10.66 y 10.60 y con razón si el francés
consumirá dos tazas de café y dos panes
de dulce él pagaría solamente 10.60
mientras que nosotros estamos pagando 14
euros que pasó aquí bueno lo que a mí se
me ocurre es que como nosotros nos
encontramos en un café de parís a las
personas que son de francia les cobran
un precio más económico que a las
personas que son extranjeras es por eso
que entonces el francés pagan menos por
cada uno de los artículos de lo que
nosotros pagamos
bueno esto tiene toda la lógica también
matemática fíjate bien que si nosotros
queremos resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones vamos a llegar a algo que no
tiene nada de sentido y para esto lo que
voy a hacer es multiplicar la ecuación
de abajo por menos entonces voy a
multiplicar no espera espera mejor podía
multiplicar directo todo por menos
entonces le voy a cambiar el signo a
todo menos 2 x menos 2 james esto es
igual a menos 10 puntos 60 y ahora sí
que me va a quedar de sumar estas dos
ecuaciones te vas a dar cuenta de que no
hay una equis ni un ay en que cumplan
simultáneamente estas dos ecuaciones
porque si yo sumo estas dos ecuaciones
estos dos se van a ir 2x menos 2 x 2 jay
menos 2 también se van entonces del lado
izquierdo me queda 0 mientras que el
lado derecho me queda 3.40 y cuando 0 es
igual a 3.40 nunca lo que quiere decir
que no existe una equis mágica que me
ayude a resolver este par de cuestiones
este sistema de ecuaciones no tiene
solución y bueno no tiene solución
porque al francés le cobran un poco
menos por ser originario de ese lugar